with just days to go before European
elections the Austrian Chancellor
struggling to restore stability to his
government since a corruption scandal
embroiled his junior coalition partner
the far-right freedom party speaking to
a short while ago Sebastian courts said
his Conservative Party was unanimous
that the allegations of bribery leveled
against his vice-chancellor
- Christian jaha will be thoroughly
investigated but course
stop stop short of firing his far-right
interior minister as he been expected a
film emerged of Austrian Vice Chancellor
struck a last week allegedly offering
government contracts for campaign
funding he has since tendered his
resignation it was this video released
by German news outlets - big event sudo
chat site own that brought Austria's
governing coalition to its knees in an
elaborate sting operation Vice
Chancellor Heinz Costanza of Austria's
far-right party FP is heard and seen
offering government contracts to a fake
Russian backer in return for campaign
help while the video was filmed in 2017
it didn't become public until last
Friday Straka resigned in disgrace and
chancellors at Bastion courts responded
by calling for early elections but
courts question whether the Interior
Minister habit Kiku also from the
far-right party should stay on in the
meantime Kiku would be in charge of
investigating this raha scandal despite
being the head of the far-right party at
the time of the sting the far-right
party however said their ministers would
collectively step back should their
interior minister be sacked
and let me draw in a car as foreign Bob
reversal who is keeping track of that
story in Vienna borrow the Austrian
Chancellor Sebastian coats was under
pressure to sack his interior minister
and he's from the far-right freedom
party but he's refused to do this do we
know what the strategy here is it seems
I mean the nation was waiting was baited
prescient particularly the Austrian and
the international press in Vienna but it
seems that Sebastian quartz is still
playing technique
tactical games it seems that he still
doesn't want to take responsibility to
set the freedom party from government
and from the coalition himself and now
he puts the responsibility for that on
to the president he said that he doesn't
want to sort of take the decision away
from him and speak before the president
would sort of come out here and say what
he wants and how he wants to proceed
which of course is just an excuse so
he's still playing games he's still sort
of trying to keep things alive and
trying to somehow keep contact to the
freedom party freedom party it is a very
different picture than what we've seen
from Sebastian cords in the past Paul
was the sort of likes a strong word very
quickly and comes out with strong
pronouncements not so in the scandal he
somehow seems to still feel fear the
fallout now earlier the far-right
freedom party also addressed journalists
what did they have to say oh they said
that they had done fantastic work in
government and that everybody should
really thank them instead of sort of
scaring as the coalition government and
that the necessary steps had been taken
the Cullens trucker had to had to step
down and Marlys things were over and
particularly nor particularly
contentious interior minister who by the
way among other problems that he caused
sort of endangered security cooperation
was neighboring countries like germany
for instance because there is no trust
in security
services in what he does Kiku came out
and said none of this is my fault I'm
the best interior minister ever and I
want to stay in office so they are
fighting they are attacking and instead
of being contrite and saying we are very
sorry about this they say we are sorry
but somehow they say it does matter we
can continue barber visa thank you very
much arenas up to date on Austrian
politics in Vienna